[Musique]
ceci est l'histoire de la maison de tel
adam strange quelqu'un du futur va venir
pour détruire cryptant de la rouge vient
ton petit fils va devenir le plus grand
héros de l'univers superman je peux vous
affirmer que nous ne sommes pas seuls
dans l'univers
on m'assure noble collector de planète
mais son vrai nom c'est vrai niark
voilà camion hier
vous retrouverez la forteresse
il est temps que tu apprennes la vérité
et azote combattez avec honneur et
combattez sans la moindre pitié
découvrez les origines de superman le
temps se sera écoulé une fois que cette
cape aura disparu elle ce sera comme si
superman avait jamais existé
la nouvelle série lizzie comics krypton
à partir de 14 mai à 21h sur syfy